the beginning of the show we call from  Washington apologize for the Russia hoax  now an apology of our own the other day  we covered the left's discovery that  knitting is racist right after that  segment aired you emailed us in volume  here a few from Linda Devine quote hey  some of those shots were of crochet not  knitting please don't lump us in with  those horrible knitters FairPoint  Charles W at this I'm offended this  video was showing crochet errs who use  one hook instead of two that is used in  knitting  make it stop exclamation point and this  from Michael in Beller quote you know a  man probably put that segment together  and has no clue about the difference  between knitting and crocheting Oh  busted it's true we would never want to  lump crochet errs in with those racist  knitters but we want to warn people that  crocheting could always choose to  self-identify as knitting so actually  there's some fluidity in the handicrafts  community that we should think about